[Applause]
[Music]
hélène Oppo Doug left hand green um we
met at a house party last week so the
way we like to play all the fines go in
the center and you win it if you land on
free parking also we're gonna be playing
the European version where all the
properties are distributed equally but
how do you win everybody wins
that's the beauty of socialism quiche
boom is 5/8 plus a triple word score you
can't place the levees that way of
course you can listen to you revel
you're doing it backwards
[Music]
so expensive
oh there's actually special today one
kiss
oh so can we send them to jail
now you can't use two hands it's just a
game oh I'm sorry I I thought the game
had rules for reason I guess we can just
do it everyone yeah let's just awesome
Jenga clamp clamp I mean 50 cc's of
amoxicillin stat coming dr. powers
vitals
call it 9:45 p.m. cause of death cutlery
of the tummy three kisses $600 are you
withholding payment if you're gonna
withhold things I can withhold things
too okay since the game we're gonna play
selfie that's not a word it is it is in
the dictionary that in my dictionary you
got to figure another word mom said it
was in a dictionary plumber house in his
room
sheesh is a good work bulbils those are
words when mom said choose another one
[Music]
you um you want to play another sure man
these guys are knocked out I think we
should leave
hmm
yeah I'm definitely playing with the cat
again all right well I got the pinball